ja es könnte sky sein dass bären mädchen
von damals
oder dieses männchen womöglich ist das
bak
der kanadisch schweizerische bären
forscher reno sommerhalder ist unterwegs
in der russischen wildnis zusammen mit
seiner lebenspartnerin ist dann nochmals
zurückgekommen
nach kamtschatka hierher wo er sechs
jahre zuvor fünf bären weisen geholfen
hat zu überleben
was ist aus den jungbären geworden
die reise zu den bären ist eine reise in
den äußersten osten russlands dorthin wo
eine 1200 kilometer lange halbinsel in
den pazifischen ozean ragt kamtschatka
in petropawlowsk der hauptstadt von
kamtschatka bereiten sich reno
sommerhalder und seine lebenspartnerin
andrea auf das abenteuer unter bären vor
einen sommer lang werden sie weit
abgelegen in einer menschenleeren
wildnis leben
da es beim parken und einkaufen ein
einiges zu denken
gang durch eine stadt die bis 1990 für
ausländer verbotenes territorium war
militärisches sperrgebiet nur 380.000
menschen leben auf der halbinsel
kamtschatka wir immerhin neunmal größer
ist als die schweiz und über die hälfte
davon wohnt in der hauptstadt
auf dem markt wird klar dass mensch und
bär in kamtschatka auch konkurrenten
sind auf der jagd nach la chs für beide
ist der wertvolle fisch
überlebenswichtig hier gibt es lachs
kaviar und lachs in beliebigen mengen
juristisch ist kann chat kann noch kaum
erschlossen
nur einzelne individuell touristen
verirren sich hierher
diesen bietet dieser souvenirladen
makabre erinnerung ans bärenland zähne
und krallen der großen tiefe will 3 für
grube ein enorm großes problem und will
3 wobei ich noch viele größtes problem
beim kombi oder nordkorea verkauft wird
da hat's noch trotzen und bayerischer
überreste von mindestens vier folgt
unsere geschichte beginnt im jahre 2004
mit einem solchen traurigen blick der
kanadische bären forscher charles
russell fand hier in einem armseligen zu
bei petropawlowsk eine bären weise die
mutter erschossen von einem jäger das
bären baby hätte noch einen sommer lang
als attraktion die besucher ergötzen
dürfen
bis es dann zu groß geworden und wohl
ebenfalls getötet worden wie wir
russell erwarb das tier und erkaufte
vier weitere bären weisen von jägern mit
dieser tierschau reist er weit weg von
jeglicher zivilisation und die bildnis
von kamtschatka
[Musik]
russell bad reno sommerhalder beim
auswildern der fünf bärenbabys zu helfen
und so wurde der kanadisch
schweizerische bärenexperte im sommer
2004 mitwirkender in einem ebenso
aufsehen erregenden wie umstrittenen
experiment menschen als bärenmutter denn
das problem dabei gewöhnen sich bären an
menschen verlieren sie die scheu und
können menschen gegenüber aufdringlich
oder zur leichten beute für wildtiere
werden
[Musik]
die unsere situation sind die kranken
die ksk ist enorm weit weg vom nächsten
dorf sind also hunderte von kilometer
wildnis kondome castros christoph kein
mensch und wir sind also die gefahrene
die kompostierbare zu mensch in
kundenhand und sich gewöhnt haben also
habituierung man stücken über das dazu
irgendwelche konflikte wird ein
besonders mutiges mädchen was crying i
knew sommerhalter schloss das bären baby
mit dem auffallend hellen fell in sein
herz und die jugendlichen spezielle
beziehung sich mit lieblingsberg sie von
einer folie an die hand der spiele
gespielt mit denen man mitunter viereck
spiel kommt und ich bin speziell dabei
natürlich habe ich die box
und so reist reno sommerhalder begleitet
von seiner lebenspartnerin andrea sechs
jahre später zurück in die
abgeschiedenheit um herauszufinden was
aus kray und den anderen jungbären
geworden ist
es ist eine reise an die südspitze der
halbinsel die nur mit dem helikopter zu
bewältigen ist denn in diesem
vergessenen teil der welt gibt es wieder
straßen noch eisenbahn und dann 250
kilometer hinter petropawlowsk kommt
endlich das ziel eine bescheidene hütte
in sicht
der helikopter entlässt die beiden mit
genügend vorrat für einen ganzen sommer
in ein menschenleeres naturparadies
eindringlinge in ein unberührtes reich
der b
auch nach sechs jahren ist reno
sommerhalder all das hier am kamp alise
vertraut geblieben
hinter der hütte steht immer noch der
stall
[Musik]
das stroh das musst du geschlafen an der
kultur aber langes die hütte nicht
braucht
normal sind dieses feature auf und in
der unter bush an schlimmste weiter
da hat der haut überall zb vor ort sind
und dort frauen schöne vorstellung
vorstellen dass völlig nach dem wechsel
2004 das sky und der burg und die andere
jungbären völlig neu sind zu hütte wo
ich gemacht hat und ihre spur
am hintereinander die hütte da und
natürlich sind sie roma sky unterburg
mit einem russischen parkwächter macht
reno sommerhalder eine erste erkundigung
näheren umkreis der hütte wer sich heute
in den reservaten von kamtschatka
bewegen will muss sich von einem
bewaffneten ranger begleiten lassen so
will es das russische gesetz
rhenus anspannung ist groß was ist aus
den jungbären geworden
bald taucht aus dem nebel ein männchen
auf ist es möglicherweise bank eines der
damaligen bären jung
die sicht ist zu neblig und dies
eindeutig zu erkennen
anderntags ist der nebel weggeputzt
erneut lässt sich das bärenmännchen am
ufer blicken
schnell erkennt renault nun dass dieser
bär erst etwa vier jahre alt ist zu jung
um bugs sein zu können
dieser wäre heute sechs jahre alt
frühmorgens der wind ist noch nicht
erwacht der gang zur morgentoilette am
see unten ist ein gang durch eine
eindringliche stille so klingt das ende
der welt oder ihr anfangen weit
abgelegen von jeglicher menschlichen
geschäftigkeit wird die intensive ruhe
zum kostbaren schatz der natur
allerdings ist der wind gegangen kommen
die stechmücken und das wohlbefinden
leidet natürlich offen ob er fort bevor
der letzten 200 jahren standen ich nur
beipflichten und immer wieder stoßen die
männer auf bären in einem pinienwald
verköstigt sich an menschen mit
pinienzapfen diese gehören neben lachs
zu den wichtigsten futterquellen der kjk
beelen zum teil kostet
kamtschatka ist bärenland die
zahlreichen spuren im sand beweisen ist
die braunbären hier gehören zu den
größten der welt menschen können bis 600
kilogramm schwer werden
noch größer ist nur der alaska kodiak
bär die größe ist wohl auf die
reichhaltige nahrung zurückzuführen
gut genährte tiere sind weniger
aggressiv zudem verschaffen die
menschenleeren weiten den tieren ruhe
und sicherheit
doch beinahe bärenmutter mit jungen ist
vorsicht angesagt die bärin hat die
eindringlinge gewittert sie nähert sich
renault spricht besänftigen zum tier
worauf sich die bären zurückzieht
hey
ok
doch eines der zwei jungen ist in
unmittelbarer nähe der menschen
geblieben weshalb die mutter zurück
kommt und dann verliert der russische
parkwächter die nerven
er schießt eine rauchpetarde ab
sommerhalter ärgert sich mächtig über
die schießerei seiner ansicht nach war
dies unnötig
ich bin gerne unterwegs mit lüth wo
bewaffnet sind will selber oftmals
studie volk sicherheit mit der waffe
kann zu menschlichem fehlverhalten so
dass man jetzt einen teil wo sich am bau
ist zum beispiel galt als aggressiver
bei abstand und erschießt und leiter
krümmel zu jedes jahr rund die vorbei in
nordamerika liga oben
doch auch reno sommerhalder geht nicht
schutzlos unter die bären seit 20 jahren
direkter in der wildnis einen speziellen
staaten pfefferspray gürtel der tafel
sprich wird eigentlich also besser im
offenburger mögliche ob dabei alles quer
oder eine pistole
ganz einfach weil die meisten
konfliktsituationen entstehen
überraschend und unerwartet
und weil man da reagiert mit der flinte
kurze die stand durchaus ähneln sie dass
man bei oder ob er ihn verletzt und wann
der verletzte bei erfurt ihr habt das
möglichst probleme mit dem teufel
spricht das nicht der fall kann
schneller reagieren als
kinderfreundliche und unverletzte bayern
für sich nicht
das ufer des kama flusses ist besonders
bereich auf einer strecke von vier
kilometern zählt renault 17 bären back
oder skies und leider nicht herunter
dafür dieses etwa fünfjährige männchen
renault nennt das tier philosoph weil es
so stoisch auf lachs lauert des lacks
fischen ist heute anstrengend denn noch
sind nicht viele fische den flusslauf
gekommen
[Musik]
eine makabre entdeckung gleich neben dem
fluss
da sind sondern es war im jahre 2004
wolken von insekten erhoben sich in die
linde sommerluft concept cars nach einem
kurzen leben endet in die tierchen im
schmelzwasser als schlämmer mal der
bärenjungen aufleben volk tut folgt
wieder leben
[Musik]
so verspielt die fünf bären weisen durch
ihre kinder tollten die tödliche gefahr
war stets nah ohne die beiden menschen
hätten die bärenkinder keine woche über
liebt die natur ist unerbittlich und
bärenmännchen sind oft hungrig
[Musik]
die tiroler als beraterin um wichtig
sich und wichtigste ist der schutz gegen
attacken von potenziell gefährliche
größere mantel ab und zu ein junger
tötet und fastet in ihrem stall und
gehege fanden die fünf jungen schutz
der elektrozaun hielt große beeren davon
ab hinter die jungen zu gelangen
[Musik]
der kegel des kmg einer 360 wohl keine
kamtschatka es herrscht ein raues klima
wie wind viel regen
ob ich die natur nach der schneeschmelze
[Musik]
für diesen fall endet der sommer in den
fängen des fleischfressenden sonnentau
[Musik]
wobei regieren der könig ist es ist ein
ort politisch bedingter reifenspur
überhaupt kosten für manche interessant
wie es geht
es gibt fragen nur so wenigen so so
wahnsinnig wertvoll sind wie zu dir oder
arbeitet sondern auch die menschliche
seele wie soviel mal baumstrunk sie mit
dass sie mit auto das mich am morgen
mittag man möchte ganz dort meistens
sogar geld das so sind die länger sind
wir rational und dann machen sich
renault und andrea ein weiteres mal auf
durchstreifen das weite land rund um den
company vulkan noch immer hoffen sie
einen der einstigen schützlinge zu
finden
ok
okay okay okay stets spricht renault zu
den bären
das hilft einerseits distanz zu wahren
und doch vertrauen zu schaffen
wann immer möglich sind rein und andrea
alleine unterwegs ohne den russischen
parkwächter sobald das gelände
unübersichtlich wird müssen sich die
zwei vorsichtig bewegen und ob nur so
weit wie im nebligen licht haben renault
und andrea kurz eine bärenmutter mit
zwei jungen gesehen größeren der
bestimmer 107 mit zwei jungbären kinder
bald abgewandert und den hammer zu
niedrigen könne keine beobachten
die bärenfamilie bleibt unsichtbar doch
die geräusche aus dem nebel sind
eindrücklich genug
dann an die nächste begegnung
ja ich war es nicht möglich den bug und
breit keine zweite fisch will man
beobachten wie man oxford und zwei
fischen sie ja in zwei kerne konzern
größte was es heißt unter bevor da hat
er reagiert auf die größe her und ist
mit meiner fraktion ihre worte das kommt
mir sehr kleiner verfügt über suchen
ich komme mir erinnerungen taxis und
2004 hat bis im august ein risiko
einziges manko meter tief und jungbären
sind oberkärnten verkennt und sind immer
denken
[Musik]
aktiviert man diese groß ich glaube
nicht dass wie blei
wo das junge mit je zwei junge plus ein
einzelner wer also ein bier pro minute
kostet ist über bleibende wie üblich
wird eine zahl die andere zwei jungen
oper im großen loch zum fraß das hat das
da am komponieren wahnsinnige beere
dichter sehr viel wäre und ich hoffe mit
cash mit vollem herzen dass sky unter
deinen ist
um im folgenden jahr überleben zu können
mussten die jungbären lernen ihr futter
selbst zu beschaffen
deshalb brachten ihnen die menschen bei
fische aus dem wasser zu holen
der beschluss
wichtig
noch waren die welpen nicht in der lage
sich selbst zu ernähren
es war notwendig die tiere zu füttern
m
denn
der grund warum das uns zusatz geführt
hat und ich wieder schneller bayern am
hans mit zu labor nach herne und hoffen
flocke michigan usa geführt wird
und die hand wähle das wohnzimmer auf
sich selber gestellt sind
das zusatz energie hat das selber so
potenziell gefährlichen endlich ernster
vorgang dass die energie hand und das
ist alles wichtig sie es war ein
spektakuläres experiment das die beiden
bären forscher im jahre 2004 in der
abgelegenheit von kamtschatka wagten
zwei männer als bärenmutter fünf welpen
sollten soweit gebracht werden dass sie
ohne menschliche hilfe überleben können
doch reno sommerhalder wollte durch das
nahe zusammenleben mit bären noch etwas
anderes beweisen
man sei aber der letzte der wahl zeige
dass die bären nötig sind
dass das bild vom bayer-team existiert
als blutrünstige bestie
das bild ist richtige licht zu rücken
oder der bayerischen mensch gegenüber
extrem toleranz die unter bayrischem
normalfall sehr friedfertig stil und
dort sind muss man sagen sie in
kategorie 3 potenziell gefälligst hier
aber chance von meiner produziert werde
ich zahle auch li na also wie genommene
strom von kokosnuss geschlagen zweiter
doch für die mutterlosen bärenjungen
galt das nicht für sie war das bärenland
eine lebensgefährliche welt
die ersatzmutter russell und somerhalder
mussten stets auf der hut sein vor
anderen erwachsenen bären
überraschend tauchte hinter der
landzunge an fremder bär auf es war eine
mutter mit zwei junge wie wird sie sich
verhalten
die situation entspannte sich als klar
wurde dass sich die bärenmutter durch
die begegnung nicht vom lachs fang
abhalten
[Musik]
immer wieder taucht und große menschen
im umkreis der hütte auf sie hatten
offenbar die witterung der welten
aufgenommen die bärenkinder spürten die
gefahr und rückten eng zusammen
zweimal musste in diesem sommer reno
sommerhalder gefährliche bärenmännchen
mit shine attacken aus der nähe der
jungen verträgen der frist wann dieser
mächtigen tiere ist gewaltig ist ein
drittel ihres körpergewichtes verlieren
sie während der winterruhe
das muss im sommer alles wieder an
gefressen werden
gegen abend kam schlechtes wetter auf
einsamer per zug entlang des kampagne
sees vielleicht findet sich noch etwas
fressbares
in ihrem stall waren die bären welten in
sicherheit vor dem sturm und vor dem
hunger großer b
der sommer 2004 ging zur neige bei den
wanderungen zogen nun auf die jungbären
voraus und es war nicht mehr einfach
ihnen zu folgen
die bärenkinder waren eigenwillig
geworden und so kam es dass bären
mädchens cry eines tages nur noch drei
spielkameraden hatte buck der bären
junge war von einem ausflug nicht mehr
zurückgekehrt
russell und somerhalder mussten davon
ausgehen dass buck von einem
bärenmännchen gefäßen worden war
plötzlich tauchte oberhalb des sees ein
bär auf kaum hatten die jungen das tier
bemerkt rannten sie los nach vier tagen
war der verloren geglaubte bank
zurückgekehrt
darin ein schöner tag für charlie
brassel und reno sommerhalder es sei
einfach wunderbar sagt damals renault in
seine kamera wunderbar hier zu sein
wunderbar mit diesen einmaligen
geschöpfen zuwandern groß unsere
erleichterung darüber dass buck nach
vier tagen wieder aufgetaucht war
gefeiert wurde mit einem frischen brot
und doch das erste bären jahr war noch
nicht überstanden
kannibalismus unter bären dieses
schicksal ali 2004 auch eine der fünf
weisen die menschlichen beschützer
konnten es nicht verhindern
große menschliche herz klopft und ist im
kopf es ist doch ob und druckgefühl von
wild kann ich also große mancher beck
sie war ein furchtbarer tötet und klasse
hat und das gebäude rehwiese passierten
vier von fünf jungbären sind also damals
über erstes lebensjahr gekommen was ist
aus diesem geworden
sechs jahre später eindeutige antworten
hat die suche bislang nicht erbracht
doch in seinen aufzeichnungen kann reno
sommerhalder von zahlreichen begegnungen
mit anderen bären berichten
[Musik]
das berner oberland oberhalb von thun
eine der zwei wohnsitze von reno
sommerhalder der andere liegt in kanada
oder kanada schweizer als tourenführer
in beeren reservaten arbeitet in der
schweiz dritter gelegentlich an
vorträgen auf aufgewachsen ist
somerhalder weit weg von bären in kloten
am rande des zürcher flughafens und
gelernt hat der koch doch nachdem er vor
25 jahren in den kanadischen rocky
mountains eine erste begegnung mit einem
schwarzen hatte richtete er sein leben
neu aus seit mehr als drei jahrzehnten
lebt somerhalder in zwei welten in jener
der menschen und jener der bären in über
20 jahren unter bären ist er autodidakt
zu einem erfahrenen kenner der großen
raubtiere geworden
image der vor 20 jahren zusammen
krachend sind das die musiker monika
horn und die alte eine begegnung kann
dieser einer hand abzählen wie viel
gefährliche begegnungen korn und das
sind 4 marc simon attackiert oder bin
von meiner bsi attacke wird
normalerweise ausgelöst nachdem beruhte
die stolz und unerwartet überrascht und
dann rennt auf 1 zu und wahnsinns tempo
um so schnell - er enthält jetzt 50
stundenkilometer unter der herner und
bringt normaler wie sie nie attacke ein
meter maniche 5 meter voraus ab dreht
sich um und rannte dann seit drei jahren
begleitet andrea heute ihren
lebensgefährten zu den bären ohne
schlechte gefühle in ihm sitzen weiß
genau wenn zurück
es war die leidenschaft für bären auch
andrea heute erfasst
die arz gehilfen wird bald mutter die
schwangerschaft hat sie zunächst
unbemerkt aus kamtschatka heimgebracht
die baldige mutter die gefahr gegenüber
bären anders beurteilen aber ich denke
dass das auch so bleibt
ich glaube nicht dass auch das andere
reno sommerhalder zu hause im berner
oberland in kanada bei andrea und bei
den wählen
doch gibt es das überhaupt so etwas wie
eine freundschaft zwischen mensch und
bär also im in den letzten 25 jahren
unter par ohne ganz klar dass bei
gefühlswelt hand wahrscheinlich nicht
einmal so unterschiedlich vorjahr aber
das richtige freundschaft koexistieren
zwischen wild lebende bär und mir jetzt
zum beispiel das ist eigentlich
ausgeschlossen
der gründer ist wieder erkennen dass
ganz korrekt kann jene paare und
vorstellig wiedergesehen und wieder mit
einzubringen und die erkennt mich ganz
klar an koch armin ihre stimme auch
visuell aber ihre erste priorität ist
überall aber ist im vorjahr ca
überlebenskampf innen oder
reno sommerhalder beschließt die suche
nach den einstigen jungbären auszudehnen
den bären können über weite strecken
wandern
in dieser gegend kommen sich beeren und
menschen öfter ins gehege
ein russischer parkwächter erklärt wie
hier eigentlich innerhalb eines
schutzgebietes kürzlich vier wildtiere
festgenommen wurden
diese hatten mit schlingen jagd auf
bären gemacht flussabwärts und der nähe
des meeres trifft sommerhalter auf eine
besonders einträgliche fischerei fischer
blockieren mit netzen die ganze fluss
breite und fangen die lachse ab die
landeinwärts zum laichen schwimmen
wollen vielleicht ist es legal
nachhaltig ist es krohn
denn die lachse die lastwagen und
lastwagen weggekarrt werden sind vor
ihrem tod noch nicht zum laichen
gekommen
zahlreiche bären spuren ziehen sich über
einen verschmutzten stirn eine undichte
regionen außer dienst
das wäre bestand überhaupt
bis heute einfluss enorm
über natürlich genießen
[Musik]
auf uralten behrendt faden streifen
renault und andrea durch das großräumige
schutzgebiet im süden kamtschatka
[Musik]
deren spuren am ufer eines flusses immer
wieder kommt es zu begegnungen mit bären
die ok
jeder bayer hat persönliche radius und
der radius das ist ein unsichtbarer
ganze schrumpft oder vergrößert sich je
nach nahrung kommen je nach stress was
ihrem lover findet mancher wo die bäder
mit einer b-elf verbringen nicht aus
sondern radius und ich also extrem
wichtig dass ich eine andere bergen über
die erkannt sei die unsichtbare grenze
bekommt nach und das mache ich mit dem
tonfall mit ihnen stimmen
dieser bär hat sich dafür entschieden
einen großen bogen um die menschlichen
eindringlinge zu machen
ein überraschendes aufeinandertreffen im
wald eine ernste situation
das unvorbereitete tier könnte zur
verteidigung die eindringlinge
attackieren der russische parkwächter
fuchtelt bereits mit dem gewehr renault
versucht mit seiner stimme die situation
zu entschärfen
keinesfalls möchte er riskieren dass
wieder geschossen wird
der bär schlägt sich ins dickicht
es rauscht so schön vom fluss her
[Musik]
die lachse sind gekommen und es lohnt
sich aufzustehen ins wasser zu steigen
[Musik]
wo viele wachsen viele wählen gleich
sieben pazifische lachs arten wandern in
kamtschatka die flüsse rauf und die
bären bedienen sich genüsslich aus
diesem reichtum
100 unübersehbar warum man concept als
eine der bären reichsten regionen der
welt bezeichnet gegen 20.000 bären
sollen auf der halbinsel leben und
gleich ein paar hundert davon haben sich
hier am kurilen sie zum lachs schloss
versammelt
hallo sky sky ist noch jung
diese
wunderschöne bevor sich einen bären zu
nähern verlangt große erfahrung
jetzt wo man auch gesehen dass ich auch
eine sehr langsam hand patrick macht
wiederaufbau schritt machen konnte dass
sie sich ein haus energie will in der
falllinie ohne auto von geyer zu lauf
der zeit michael dominanzverhalten unter
zeigt schon dass du dich und das haben
wir gemacht im roboterhand und wie immer
eigentlich ja ihre ehre und zeigt dass
man sie tolerieren wo sie ist und mit
diesem wissen was somerhalder sich
mitten unter die bären gemeinschaft von
kamtschatka zu mischen
also zum audi mutter holte sich
rechtfertigt die verbringe viel zeit
getrennt
für boeing ist klagen wollen erinnert
sich eine sky so nah an eine mutter mit
jungen heranzugehen erscheint allerdings
recht leichtsinnig unverantwortlich gab
also warme wenig kenntnis oktober ist
ganz klar wurde dass man von wörter wie
die jungtiere feiern blieb aber jene
fall wenn mich alle mutter bauen
dein herz normalgewichts tour der mit
positiveren schon länger kann dass sie
mir kann dass man wieder die
vertrauensbasis haben können und ich
kann jetzt also dutzende vw bulli vor
mir kam mit juwel von verschiedenen
alter jährig zweijährigen zwischen drei
mal zu meiner konflikt wird eine b elf
will selber möglich ist als
vertrauensvoll und begrüße bei rinne ist
das ja ein tag möglich weniger stunden
die anderen bereits mehrere tage bis zur
vertrauen das vertrauen basierenden
hofbauer
abseits von den großen lachs vorkommen
abseits von den anderen bären entdeckten
renault und andrea am ufer ein
verlassenes tages bett daneben kothaufen
die zeigen dass sich dieses tier vor
allem von behren ernährt wenig später
liegt eine mutter mit zwei jungen im
bett je weniger lachse hat dafür auch
weniger gefährliche menschen
[Musik]
es wurde herbst im jahre 2004 bereits
bedeckte frischer schnee den kambala die
wohl kran das satte grün der landschaft
wurde allmählich von herzlichen faden
verdrängt vier der fünf bären welten
hatten ihren ersten sommer überlebt sie
wurden nun über 40 kilogramm und waren
kaum mehr zuwanderung zu bewegen
die tiere waren träge worden der
winterschlaf kündigte sich an alle
rasseln und reno sommerhalder hatten
eine frisch gegrabene winter höhle weil
es ausgewachsenen bären entdeckt an den
wänden waren kratzspuren der krallen
sichtbar
auch die vier jungen bären werden sich
bald in eine höhle zurückziehen
die beiden menschen werden ihnen noch
helfen eine solche zu bauen
eine letzte hilfe bevor die bärenkinder
auf sich allein gestellt sein werden
es war allmählich zeit abschied zu
nehmen
sky
plätze gebe als erkennen
sechs jahre sind seither vergangen und
reno sommerhalder zieht durch die welten
ist auf der suche nach den einstigen
jungwähler
doch woher nimmt er die gewissheit dass
diese damals den ersten winter überhaupt
überlebt haben die handwerker carbon
helikopter überflog macht hat im
frühling von 2005 und der hat uns
bericht erstattet also vier spuren zählt
hat uns der winter höhen usa sind im
april 2005 und müssen also sicher dass
alle vier der wind über abkaufen jung
blond
der innenminister hat sky gegen jegliche
form dunkel todesfall und cisco webex
sie
es sind letzte begegnungen im wilden
kamtschatka mit seinen vulkanen seinem
wind seinen bären friedlich ließen die
großen tiere die zwei eindringlinge aus
der schweiz in ihrem reich gewählt
der sommer ist bald vorbei damit die
suche nach den einstigen schützlingen
reno sommerhalder hat viele bären
getroffen
doch ob sky oder back oder andere der
vier jungen bären darunter waren das
kann er nicht mit bestimmtheit sagen
vielleicht vielleicht auch nicht aber
was für mich noch viel wichtiger sie ich
sehe da aber es wurden wieder zu sehen
wie das gespür und sehe dass der
population der bärenpopulation der tenor
umgegangen ist die letzte baujahre dass
all die verschiedenen altersgruppen die
ganze population strukturen genomen
taucht wir haben pro tag 25
wenn der so sehr intaktes ökosystem
vorgefunden was für mich noch viel
wichtiger ist als drei und der park
wieder zu finden
[Musik]
[Applaus]